Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, we're getting
back into one of those phases, very much reminiscent
of 20/20, where things are changing relatively
quickly when it comes to the pandemic and
the trajectory over the next two, three, four
or five months.
And part of the question that has been increasingly
asked is, will there be a third vaccine dose?
Will there be a recommendation for some or
maybe even most people to get a third dose
of the coronavirus vaccine in order to have
stronger protection against the Delta variant
and or future variants?
And over the last 24 hours, the answer seems
to increasingly be pointing to, yes, let's
review a couple of articles about this CNN
article.
Pfizer data suggests third dose of covid-19
vaccine strongly boosts protection against
Delta variant.
Now, there are some important details here.
Let's review a third dose of the Pfizer Bion.
Tek covid-19 vaccine can strongly boost protection
against the Delta variant beyond the protection
afforded by the standard two doses.
New data released by Pfizer on Wednesday suggests
the data posted online suggests that levels
of antibodies that can target the Delta variant
grow five fold in people aged 18 to 55 who
get a third dose of the vaccine among people
ages 65 to 85.
The Pfizer data suggest antibody levels that
should protect against Delta grow 11 four
fold more than following a second dose.
Now, it's not likely that in older folks they
get to a higher level of antibodies.
It's that because in older folks it's looking
like the antibodies start to diminish.
It is getting them up at a greater multiple
because they are starting with a lower base
rate.
It's just a simple mechanism of of understanding
the base rate.
Understand that this is this is the Keyline.
The data involved tests of 23 people and have
not yet been peer reviewed or published.
It is very, very early in this.
But there are other countries studying this
as well, which we will get to in a moment.
So if you were wondering, why does your CDC
vaccination card have more than two slots,
even though up until now the protocol has
been two doses, this may well be why it's
another important detail.
It's not clear if boosted antibody levels
actually correlate to better protection or
if that extra protection is even needed.
The U.S., CDC and the U.S. CDC says the current
vaccines protect people well against all the
common variants.
So there's a bunch of different factors here.
One is.
Does Pfizer have a financial interest in everybody
getting a third?
Sure, you could say that, that there's no
question about that.
They stand to make a lot of money.
If all of a sudden, instead of two doses for
every American, it's three doses for every
American and people in other countries as
well.
The other question is, even with diminished
antibodies, do you have enough antibodies
that you would still, in most cases, be immune
or at least unlikely to get seriously ill?
Because that's the point of a vaccine.
If we say if cases mean mostly colds and vaccinated
people, cases become less important.
It's sort of like well as the cases of the
flu, cases of colds, et cetera.
We've talked about that before.
We don't need to go over it again.
Needless to say, other countries are also
investigating this third dose idea and Israel
is going to be moving forward on it.
As you can see here, the Israeli health ministry
recommends a third covid shot for older Israelis.
Most experts on the committee argue for a
covid booster shot for Israelis 60 and above.
As the Delta variant spreads.
Experts advising the health ministry have
recommended that older people receive a third
dose of the coronavirus vaccine, though they
disagree on whether the cohort should start
at 60 years old, 65 or 70.
Some of the data presented at a discussion
Wednesday suggested that the vaccine's effectiveness
in preventing severe symptoms among 60 year
olds and above has dropped to eighty one percent
from 97 percent in January.
While most panel members favored a booster
shot for anyone 60 or older, others suggested
that the bar be raised to 65 or 70.
The Health Ministry's director general will
make the final decision.
We are seeing a dramatic drop in the level
of immunity, and we know the elderly respond
less to vaccines than the young.
But we don't have this data for covid-19.
Tuesday, the prime minister declared Israel
was very close to making a decision on covid
booster shots and on obtaining additional
doses needed.
So for me, there is every indication here
that we're going in the direction of a third
dose, at least for some portion of the US
population, even though there is still some
lack of clarity about even if your antibodies
diminish, you may still have enough antibodies
to mostly protect you from the disease.
And again, this is one of those situations
where other countries are saying third doses,
guys were desperate for some vaccine.
Send us anything, we'll take anything.
We'll even give us first doses for some people.
And in the US, we have this incredibly an
extraordinarily privileged situation where
anybody can just walk in and get a first dose
and a second dose if there's a decision made,
about third doses that that we go in the direction
of, yes, those are going to be widely available.
And yet tons of people in the United States
still don't even want to go and get vaccinated.
We are also, fortunately, and it's only a
slight improvement, but fortunately, we are
starting to see vaccination numbers go up
in the United States.
Over the last couple of days.
We had a couple of consecutive days where
there were about three hundred and seventy
five thousand new vaccinations, meaning not
when it's a two dose regimen.
If you just look at the number of doses, you
don't know how many people that represents
about three hundred and seventy five thousand
new people per day going and getting a vaccine.
Now, you look at that and you say, oh, my
goodness, that's zero point one percent of
the population.
That's an improvement.
And it's very depressing when we could be
vaccinating tens of millions of more people.
But the fact that the numbers are going in
the right direction rather than the wrong
direction is certainly something that we can
be glad about.
So that's the latest on third doses.
What I want to talk about next is increasingly
understand the framing here.
Businesses making decisions that they judge
are good business decisions for them.
OK, let's get into that next.
No shirt.
No shoes, no vaccine, no service.
OK, that is legally something that businesses
can say in the same way that you can have
requirements for going into a business that
might include you've got to be wearing shoes
or you've got to be wearing a shirt for public
health purposes, for sanitation purposes.
Business is going to say you've got to be
vaccinated against covid-19.
We've seen the start in other countries and
we're now seeing it start in the United States.
Restaurants tell customers no vaccine, no
service as Delta variant spreads.
This is an interesting article from MarketWatch
as covid cases increase.
Establishments are requiring customers to
prove they are fully vaccinated and they're
running into protests in the process.
Not surprisingly, as covid-19 cases surged
through the U.S., a growing number of dining
and drinking establishments are turning unvaccinated
customers away, saying their businesses can't
risk possibly exposing patrons and staff to
the virus.
But these Novavax no service decisions have
sparked controversy with anti vaccination
groups and individuals saying they constitute
a violation of civil rights.
Some states, such as Florida and Texas, have
enacted laws that essentially prevent private
businesses from imposing these bans on the
unvaccinated.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about,
despite what Republican Trumpy and Gov. Rhonda
Santurce has done in Florida trying to ban
any such vaccine requirements, mayors all
over Florida in different parts of Florida
are defying Ron Ron DeSantis and saying, no,
let's do the vaccine requirements.
Let's allow the vaccine requirements.
Anyway, we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show.
The bars and restaurants putting the vaccine
requirements in place range from individually
owned ones to small chains.
In San Francisco, a local bar owner organization
representing more than 300 establishments
announced Monday its calling for bar customers
to show proof of vaccination or a negative
covid test to enter bars.
Italy has started doing this.
Parts of Spain are going to be doing this.
France, I'm sorry, France, not Italy.
Italy maybe is going to do it.
I'm not actually sure.
On Italy, patrons who don't meet the requirement
will be allowed to sit outside at local drinking
spots.
Ben Blakeman, president of the San Francisco
Bar Owner Alliance and a bar proprietor himself,
said it is hard to ignore the fact that covid-19
can easily be spread by unvaccinated individuals.
So at a time when there is a dramatic rise
in cases, the ban is simply necessary.
It seems to be the easiest and fastest way
to protect people, he said.
City Winery, a national bar and restaurant
chain that offers live music by prominent
artists.
Actually, our friend Matisyahu is soon going
to be playing some city winery gigs in New
York and I believe in Boston.
City Winery already had a vaccine requirement
in place for its New York City location.
After serving customers throughout the country
over the last few days by email, it is decided
to extend the requirement at all its establishments
starting next week.
More than 75 percent of customers who responded
to the survey supported the vaccine requirement.
He also said that when he is at his New York
City venue and talks to those on hand before
a performance, he gets a standing ovation.
This is going to be the new battle.
And we are later, I'm going to show you it's
going to look like it's a five year old.
It's actually a full grown adult.
Going on a complete tantrum about masks on
the floor of the House of Representatives,
we are going to see a certain contingent of
the American population go absolutely cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs based on here we go now businesses
not regulated in this way by the government.
In other words, the government is not regulated.
Some states are trying to, but the government
is not regulating businesses in so far as
telling them you must or you cannot or whatever
put in place a vaccine requirement.
Businesses are deciding for themselves the
way Republicans claim they want businesses
to be able to do.
Hey, are we better off overall with a vaccine
requirement to come to our establishment or
not?
And if people see the vaccine requirement
and they say that's terrible, sir, we hate
it, then they can choose not to go to that
establishment.
The business is able to make the decision
they believe is best for them.
They may be right.
They may be wrong, but it's their right to
make that decision.
And then you as a consumer can say, I want
to reward this business with my money, voting
with my dollars because I like their rule
or I am going to avoid this business.
You might choose to avoid a business because
they do have a vaccine requirement.
they do not have a vaccine requirement.
And either way, everybody is making the choice
that is best for them.
You don't have a right to go unvaccinated
to a private restaurant.
It will be up to you to figure out where you
want to go.
Now, that's that's the libertarian small government,
you know, argument for what is going on.
I have a sense that so-called small government
conservatives are not going to take it the
way that I am laying it out.
They are going to say it's a violation of
the Constitution.
It's a violation of Hypatia, hippo, rhino,
elephant, giraffe, whatever.
Right.
They'll they'll come up with what?
It's a violation.
I've I've been violated and it is going to
be the latest.
Seventy to ninety six hour scandal on right
wing media.
That's the expectation.
I assume by Monday we're going to start to
see it.
Speaking of important Mondays, by the way,
we are now one to, I guess, three Mondays
away from the sixteenth anniversary of The
David Pakman Show, also known as the sixteen
year wait.
No, sixteen year anniversary is that's that's
an oxymoron, right?
Sixteen year anniversary.
It's the sixteenth anniversary that I'm sure
of.
It will be Monday, August 16th.
We are doing a one day membership special.
We're calling it a membership bomb, but it's
a bomb only in the best sense.
There's nothing violent of any kind.
And if you're interested in signing up at
an extreme discount to celebrate this sixteen
year anniversary, please sign up for my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com.
And then Monday, August 16th, you'll be notified.
Hey, here is how you sign up and take advantage
of
the discount.
All right, we just have too much to get to
today for me to spend the next 20 minutes
talking about membership so I won't.
I hope people will accept my apology.
And people I'm sure we're looking forward
to that.
Let's get right into some notable discussions
from The David Pakman Show Subrata.
You can join more than thirty two thousand
of our viewers and listeners on the sub Reddit,
David Pakman, Dotcom, Reddit.
Join the discussion and a lot of important
things being discussed there.
Here is a question that has been coming up
a lot.
And there was a very interesting discussion
and poll of our audience.
The question is, do you guys have any sympathy
for anti AXA's who wind up getting sick with
covid-19?
And we're going to look at such a story in
a moment.
And the the majority in our audience said
no, but I don't wish death on anybody or no,
they should have known better.
So a lot of not feeling any sympathy for people
who don't get vaccinated and later get sick.
Some in the audience said, I have a little
bit of sympathy, but not much.
And by far the least common answer among our
audience was, yes, I do have sympathy for
the anti boxers who get sick, and I hope they
all have a speedy recovery.
I'm sort of in that minority and I understand
that there is a significant level of ignorance
and disconnection from reality in many of
these people.
But I do consider themselves victims and I
know the AGYEMAN will call in and say, David,
you're too empathetic.
That's not going to get you anywhere.
Maybe that's the case.
But I think that I mean, listen, I think it's
totally normal to resent the anti boxers.
There is no doubt about it.
They're extending this.
We have widespread vaccines available here
and they're choosing not to get one.
And this furthers the spread and it increases
death and it increases hospitalization.
I get it.
So I understand resenting.
But also when I hear that someone like, for
example, pro Trump anti VAX radio hosts Phil
Valentine is now on a ventilator, which we
will talk about in a moment.
I don't I don't feel good about it.
It doesn't make me I don't like that.
So that's the point of view, I guess, of the
audience.
Another post from the sub Reddit called Clearing
Up the arguments over mask wearing brings
up a couple of interesting questions.
And it says now that the CDC is recommending
indoor mask wearing again, even for vaccinated
Americans.
I'm already seeing the insane outrage and
ignorance from conservatives we saw last year.
I thought this would be a good subrata it
to make sense of the issue because they feel
like I'm losing my mind.
So I'm just clearing this up.
Feel free to discuss.
There's plenty of evidence to show that the
vaccinated covid patients do not end up in
the hospital.
In fact, they experience very little symptoms.
This is like the flu shot, right?
I remember the one year I didn't get the flu
shot.
I got the flu.
I was bedridden for a week.
I got the flu this last year with a flu shot,
had a minor headache and sniffles this is
the way to debunk any argument stating the
vaccines don't work.
See, we told you then you have the mask wearing.
Why would I wear a mask if I'm if I'm vaccinated?
Well, because you can still transmit it to
the unvaccinated.
We might have some people say they don't care
about giving it to unvaccinated people, which
honestly, I find perfectly OK.
But that's the reason the CDC is recommending
masks.
Right.
Lastly, why do these conservatives think mask
wearing is about government control?
I don't get it.
Biden hasn't taken advantage of government
control at all.
That's what they always said.
It's a slippery slope.
No, they're just going to want you to wear
a mask because we haven't.
One hundred percent defeated this thing, right?
It's insane to me how little I can empathize
with their views right now, unless I'm the
crazy one, which is what I'd like you all
to help me with, because to me, these people
must be very, very stupid and lack any critical
thinking skills.
How is it possible to reason with them how
you can't?
And so the pretzel that you find yourself
in trying to talk to these people and saying,
how can I just get them to get it?
Why don't they understand it?
Unfortunately, we can both feel sympathy and
empathy for people who get sick and resent
them and be going out of our minds because
any conversation with them is an exercise
in futility and frustration and desperation.
It's all of the above.
And, you know, there's this concept from I
don't know if it's I don't know if I don't
know what area of psychotherapy it's from,
but it's basically being able to hold to conflicting
ideas at the same time.
Right.
You know, in a relationship, it might be that
you find yourself incredibly angry at someone
who hasn't treated you right.
But yet you still love them because they're
family or whatever the case may be.
And you've got to kind of hold both ideas.
It's the same thing here.
And the word empathy keeps coming up.
We can both empathize and sympathize with
people who are getting sick without being
vaccinated and be mad, resentful and frustrated
up to the wazoo because of those very same
people.
I think it makes absolutely perfect sense.
Joined the discussion.
Weigh in yourself at David Pakman Dotcom.
Read it.
All right.
I'm going to show you video here of an adult.
This is a.
All grown human Republican Congressman Chip
Roy from Texas, throwing a tantrum, the likes
of which you would expect from a two year
old in a sandbox, about what?
About mask wearing, given the new guidance
from the CDC about the spread of the Delta
variant, in great part because of unvaccinated
people, the House of Representatives is looking
at reimposing a mask requirement on the floor
of the House.
And in fact, I believe they have done it.
There are some members that are protesting
at one such member is Roy.
You will notice if you're watching that like
a toddler, Marjorie Taylor Green.
This is such an attention seeking behavior
in Asby.
I know a lot of people who participate in
these attention seeking behavior behaviors.
You know who I'm talking about?
It's you go to a restaurant and there's someone
at the next table over talking really, really
loudly about how much money they make or how
smart they are or the vacation they went on,
not for the benefit of the people at their
table, but the for the benefit of the people
at surrounding tables.
It's an attention seeking behavior.
Marjorie Taylor Green does this all the time
on the House floor when when the debate is
about masks or vaccines or abortion or whatever,
she plants herself right behind the person
who is speaking and ranting that's going on
here.
Let's listen to Chip Roy.
Absolutely lose his mind.
This is not a two year old folk folks.
Take a look
Speaker 2: here on the people's house.
We got to go around and see, OK, we can't
come to the floor.
I can't excuse my constitutional duty unless
I wear a mask, which isn't vaccines or masks.
Speaker 1: Does he not understand it or is
he pretending not to understand it?
Speaker 2: The vaccines work or they don't
work.
Do the math works or they don't work.
I'd like to know which it is.
I'd like Dr. Valge to come down and answer
a single question about natural immunity.
Speaker 1: And then you, Margery Taylor Green,
nodding like Chip Roy is making some kind
of incredibly salient point here,
Speaker 2: infected with the virus.
Do you have immunity or are they just going
to go around poking people saying you must
take a vaccine?
Oh, but sorry, the vaccine doesn't work.
You must wear a mask.
This institution is a sham and we should adjourn
and shut this place down.
Speaker 1: And so there a Marjorie Taylor
Greene standing up and cheering and clapping
and so on.
So this was the point.
They wanted to adjourn the House proceedings
over the mask guidelines.
I mean, it's sort of like the congressional
equivalent of if I can't play in the sandbox,
I'm going to poop in it so nobody else can
either.
Write apologies for the I'm still thinking
of that pastor playing with the dog poop yesterday.
And then we move on to Kevin McCarthy.
Kevin McCarthy.
Mark McCarthy is the House minority leader.
And it gives me great pleasure to call him
the minority leader because Republicans did
lose control of the House.
And he goes on a rant about all the things
he claims Democrats want to control.
I don't even know where he's getting this
stuff,
Speaker 3: but it's just like their philosophy.
They want a mandate.
They want to impose.
They want to tell you when you can go to school,
when you can
Speaker 1: eat, when you can eat that.
Does anybody know what that's about?
Is that about like lunchtimes at school?
Is there actually something he's referring
to or is that just more trash gutter trash
from these people?
Speaker 3: You know what they're going to
do if you walk into this building without
a mask, they're going to charge you five hundred
dollars.
Why?
Because they got the power to do it.
Speaker 1: How ominous.
What an ominous thing.
Now, there was one guy and I just absolutely
love this.
There was one guy who wasn't having any of
this garbage, and it's our friend, Tim Ryan.
Tim Ryan has been a guest on the show.
Really interesting guy.
You know, you don't have to agree with him
on every single policy, but just, you know,
he's an informed guy.
He has interests.
He's intellectually curious.
He knows about mindfulness.
He knows about alternative energy.
He's just a good guy delivering an impassioned
takedown of these absurd Republicans.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Somebody represents the hot spots,
right?
And they get on a plane and they fly here
and they interact with all of us.
And then we leave here and we go home to our
families.
Some take care of their sick parents.
Some take care of kids who may have an autoimmune
disorder.
And I just find it absolutely immature and
appalling to somehow diminish it, to try to
score cheap political points, right?
That's exactly what we saw a few minutes ago.
Well, yeah, that is beneath a minority leader
of one of the major political parties.
Speaker 1: In the end, it's sort of not any
more.
In other words, Trump pianism has reduced
the dialog so much that it's actually no longer
beneath the Republican Party to do what they
did earlier ited states of America,
Speaker 3: saying we should take no caution.
Oh, that someone from a hot spot, hot spot
is working in this chamber and could potentially
get someone infected that could go home to
a sick parent or are immune compromised kid.
That is beneath us.
That is beneath us and it's certainly beneath
leadership here in Washington, D.C.,
Speaker 1: it should be, but unfortunately
it is just par for the course.
Now, this is how Trump in politics works.
Kevin McCarthy is a absolutely perfect example
of that.
So an absolute mess on the House floor.
And these people and by the way, many of these
people are vaccinated, even though they talk
about, oh, mandatory jabs and they're vaccinated,
they're back.
But if they were to just say it, they would
suffer politically.
That's the reality.
And so many of them are hiding their own vaccination
will actually get back to that a little bit
later.
I do want to update people on another one
of these anti vaccine trump people who is
very sick with covid.
It's actually getting worse.
I don't like to hear this.
I told you about radio host Phil Vallentine.
Phil Valentine was a he says he was vaccine
skeptical.
It's basically an anti backstroke.
And pro Trump guy told you earlier this week
that he was very sick with covid hospitalized
and on oxygen.
But his family and the radio station where
he works made it a point to say he is not
on a ventilator.
That has now changed.
Phil Valentine is now on a ventilator amid
his covid-19 battle.
Conservative radio talk show host Phil Valentine,
currently hospitalized with covid, has now
been placed on a ventilator, according to
a tweet from Nashville's Supertech ninety
nine seven WTN, the move to the ventilator
was made out of an abundance of caution.
The station's tweet goes on to say the host
made the decision to be put on a ventilator
to give his body some much needed rest.
Valentine had previously been on oxygen.
Now, in terms of the rest, I think when you're
on the ventilator, you're also sedated.
So maybe it maybe it's as much about that.
I don't we just don't know.
It's sort of a cryptic way to say it.
The statement from the radio station states
they are confident he will pull through and
thank everyone for continued prayers.
In a July 11 Facebook post, Valentine confirmed
he tested positive for covid.
He spoke about his battle with the virus on
his show.
I think I'm on the other side of it, he said
as he described coughing, congestion and fatigue.
That hurts like crap, he said.
I'm certainly moving forward, but not in a
straight line.
Valentine previously expressed disagreement
with mask mandates, stating hospitals were
never in danger of being overwhelmed by covid
patients.
That's a conspiracy theory.
It's completely untrue.
He's been critical of the vaccine's voicing
concerns over safety.
Mark Valentine, Phil's brother, spoke with
News two earlier this week.
At the time, he said Phil slightly improved
but said we haven't turned the corner to recovery
yet.
He went on to say Valentine would be the most
pro vaccine person you've ever seen when he
returns.
So, listen, it's good that Phil Valentine
is now a pro vaccine.
I hope that he recovers and is able to be
a pro vaccine advocate because he would be
speaking to his anti vax Tennessee audience.
This is exactly the group that needs to hear,
hey, look at what happened to me.
Go and get yourself the vaccine.
But this is another cautionary tale.
I take no pleasure in the fact that Phil Valentine
is now even sicker.
I'm hoping that he gets better.
And part of why I'm hoping it gets better
is not because I think he doesn't you know,
it's not about not resenting his anti-war
activism.
I resent it.
But if he does recover and becomes a vaccine
advocate, it could actually save lives because
he's going to be speaking to exactly the people
who need to hear it.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us, The David Pakman
Show, and follow us on tech talk.
Yeah, can you believe it?
Almost fifty thousand followers on tech talk.
Also David Pakman
show their.
It's great to welcome back to the program
today, Nick mid-July, who is CEO at Ritholtz
Wealth Management and also founder of Of Dollars
and Data, a data focused personal finance
blog to which I subscribe.
Great to have you back on, Nick.
Speaker 4: Nice to see you again, David.
Speaker 1: So, OK, many in my audience are
millennials or they know millennials or they've
heard of millennials at least, and are probably
familiar with some of the headlines that say
millennials dramatically worse off financially
than their parents, than their grandparents.
The millennial generation is just financially
a disaster.
Oftentimes, student loans, combined with stagnant
wages are pointing to, et cetera, et cetera.
OK, so that may be true.
I think I want to understand how these things
are being calculated first and foremost.
So maybe let's start there.
When those headlines are written, what are
they based on?
Speaker 4: They are based on.
So one of the big stats that people use, they
look at the share of total wealth that every
generation owns.
And so the Federal Reserve basically says,
OK, here's one generation they could use years
and ages and years and years boomers, here's
Gen X, here's millennials, et cetera.
And they just say, like, what percentage of
the total wealth do they owned by these estimates?
And the percentage that millennials own right
now is smaller than the percentage that boomers
owned at the same age and smaller than, what,
Gen X under the same age?
That only issue with that is the pie has gotten
considerably bigger.
Right.
So that's that's something to consider.
And then you also have to look at like, OK,
adjust for inflation.
You have to adjust for the number of households
there are.
Now, there are, I think, more millennials
and boomers.
But at one point, I mean, you go back five,
six years, that wasn't the case.
Boomers are the largest generation.
But, you know, as as that generation dies
off, you know, millennials basically are taking
over.
So I think there is some truth to that.
There is truth to the student debt loads.
There's truth to stagnant wages.
Those things are happening.
But I think you have to look at a much broader
picture.
I think those are they're focusing on a very
small selection of millennials and not the
entire if you look across all millennials,
you kind of aggregate things and look across
the entire generation.
I don't think it's as dire as the media makes
it out to be.
Speaker 1: So make of that case.
I mean, how can we how do you defend empirically
the idea that millennials actually aren't
aren't so poorly off?
Speaker 4: Yes.
So if you look at inflation adjusted per capita
per household, net worth the same.
I'm using the same data source that they used
to say millennials are poor, using the same
data source from the Federal Reserve.
You look at those trends over time, and I
would have to say I could send you a charts
and my blog post, but there's a chart which
shows like, OK, here's where millennials are.
Here's where boomers were at the same age.
And like the lines are lining up.
It's like they're on the same trajectory.
It's like people are just getting older and
they're we're gaining more wealth, like even
during covid.
The thing I remember, it's like millennials
added one trillion dollars in total wealth
to their generation during covid, which was
obviously a very bad time financially for
a lot of people.
So we hear this stuff and like I'm not saying
that there are people struggling.
I'm not trying to debate that.
That's definitely true.
And I can in the data, we see that clearly
the bottom 10 percent of the millennial generation
or younger households in general are far,
far worse off than any bottom 10 percent,
10 percent of the younger generations previously.
And it's because of debt load.
It's because of, you know, job prospects.
There's a lot of reasons why this is happening,
but you can clearly see it in the data.
So if you're looking like, yeah, there's a
lot of people struggling and if you focus
on that segment, you can write stories about
that which are legitimate at the same time
to then paint that subset to the rest of everyone
else.
I don't think it's completely fair.
And so I'm just trying to bring a little bit
more balance and more object, more activity
to this kind of discussion.
Speaker 1: Now, when we talk about the other
thing is some of these terms, when we talk
about wealth, are we talking about assets
or are we talking about net worth?
Because in, for example, inflation could lead
to people having more assets in a nominal
sense.
But then if you account for liabilities, then
it's not so.
So I think it's important to understand what
we're looking at.
Speaker 4: Yes, we were.
And I apologize when I was talking about those
charts and wealth.
I'm talking about net worth assets minus liabilities.
And so like, yes, financial assets are higher,
but debt is also higher, not non.
Mortgage debt is higher for millennials, without
a doubt.
If you look at them and they're taking it
on earlier than that Gen X did and which who
took it on even earlier than the boomers did.
Right.
So looking at those types of charts, you can
see that like, yes, we are we have more debt
than than any other generation.
But the same time we do have a little bit
more financial assets.
So it kind of evens out on on aggregate.
But I remember aggregate isn't what people
feel.
People feel their personal situation.
Sure.
And just brush it away.
But I don't think it's as much of a crisis
as the media portrays it.
That's that's I think where I'm kind of getting
at.
Speaker 1: Let's pick one kind of sub issue
within all this that sometimes talked about,
like, for example, home ownership.
And that's another one where you will often
see millennials are have a lower homeownership
rate than prior generations.
And then there will be people who say, well,
yeah, that's because the cost of living has
gotten so.
Significantly out of sync with wages, and
then you add to that the college debt, and
then you also add to that that people are
just getting married later on.
And so there may be sort of cultural reasons.
How how about an issue like that?
How should we be thinking about the real significance
of homeownership for millennials?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
So I think you brought up a lot of the key
issues.
There are people getting married later.
That's a cultural reason.
And usually when home ownership would happen,
like, for example, I'm thirty one and single
right now, if I were to buy, I could buy a
house.
But then if I end up getting married in the
next couple of years or something, I'm going
to need a bigger house.
So I would just pay the transaction costs
to do that.
So I know I'm not going to be buying any time
soon until that part of my lifestyle is more
cemented.
That's the cultural reasons are true in terms
of you actually look at rent rent over income
levels.
Those levels haven't changed that much.
You look at it after tax income or divided
by rent.
You can look at that ratio.
Those ratios are kind of flat.
And so I did look at that in some way.
So rent is not necessarily all that much higher.
So I wouldn't say that, like, OK, wages were
stagnant.
If you look at this analysis like five years
ago, this is very true.
But since twenty, fourteen, twenty, fifteen,
things have kind of boomed and like incomes
have gone up a lot.
And a lot of these stories that were written
in twenty thirteen, twenty, fourteen, twenty
fifteen, they don't look as true now because
using the same data I have, if you go and
stop the story in twenty thirteen, it looks
pretty dire for millennials.
I'm not going to lie, but you move four to
five years.
It's like, oh things have caught up, you know,
things are starting to happen and it isn't
looking as bad now.
And so that's kind of the thing I see.
So in terms of home ownership, yeah, there's
a lot of issues there.
And obviously prices have gone up, but rates
are lower.
So like the the cost of a mortgage may not
necessarily be that much higher or similar,
but it's a complex topic.
There's a lot of issues to unpack there.
Speaker 1: So big picture.
I mean, what what is the kind of defining
narrative overall about how we should understand
the financial picture of millennials in the
aggregate understanding, as you say, that
people people's personal experience is their
lived experience and that that's sort of what
it's going to feel like at the individual
level, at the aggregate is is there not much
of a story in terms of how millennials are
doing relative to prior generations financially?
Speaker 4: I don't I don't think I think it
depends.
When you look as I said, if you go back a
couple of years, it looks pretty bad.
But now things of, you know, incomes have
gone up a bit, like assets have gone up as
a result.
Because of that, millennials aren't looking
as they don't look like they're struggling
as much.
However, I think the real story to take away
here is there is a subset of millennials that
is struggling and I think they need help.
And so whether that's right now, the there's
debates about whether we should cancel student
loan debt or.
Right.
We should have.
Why not have a tax credit?
Every American gets a ten thousand dollar
tax credit that you can use towards education.
If you never use it, you lose it.
If you've used it in the past, you can use
in the future.
If you paid off student loan debt ten years
ago, guess what?
You can use it.
You can write it off that.
I don't know exactly how that would work,
but something like that, where it's going
to feel fair, everyone gets it technically
and it would help those people that are in
debt at least somewhat.
So I don't know if that's the solution, but
I think there are people that need help and
painting the picture of all millennials are
struggling.
I think that makes boomers look at millennials
say, oh, they're just lazy versus like, no,
just some millennials are struggling.
Then boomers may look at this and say, oh,
that's the real problem, we should help them.
I think it's it's much easier to help a subset
of people than to be like, oh, I'm not just
going to do a massive wealth transfer to millennials,
which I don't think we need.
I think it's like any sort of thing like that.
I think it needs to be very targeted to the
people who are actually, like, in a really
bad position.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, that's one of the
criticisms, one of the criticisms that comes
up about the just the blanket cancelation
of student debt is that it wouldn't really
be that progressive.
And I'm not saying politically progressive.
I'm saying in terms of who it's who it's hitting
because there are lots of people who have
chosen to take on debt, even though even though
their financial position today is actually
quite good and you're going to be hitting
them even though their ability to repay is
actually significant, is that a fair criticism
of like a blanket student debt cancelation
versus something like what you're talking
about?
Speaker 4: Yes, I see.
The issue is like, OK, personal responsibility.
All I chose not to go.
And you have to realize, like what is only
a third of Americans end up getting a college
degree anyways.
And so, like for me, I'm obviously in a bubble
where, like, most of my friends are college
educated.
So like to me it's like, oh, everyone has
a college degree.
But remember, it's only about a third of Americans
creating a policy only for a third of Americans
is something that like and it's not like Age-Based
or something like Social Security.
It's it's something that's going to be hard
to pass.
That's why I'm saying, like, try and come
up with something that's like fair.
Maybe you come up with a policy where you
can use your these credits for a technical
school, you can use it for anything, you can
use it for a coding boot camp.
You know, if you expand it to not just be
college debt, I think you can get a lot more
Americans in on it and it would actually help
people.
So I think you need to just rethink that.
And that's also one of the reasons why I like
canceling student loan debt.
Well, that's that would be helpful to some
people I.
A lot of people will see that and say, like,
yeah, that's I why am I paying for someone
else's thing?
So I think you need to kind of make it a little
bit more fair to get a lot more Buy-In from
from everyone.
I don't know how to do that.
But yeah, this is
Speaker 1: the Andrew Yang idea was to include
trade school.
And that's not unique to Andrew Yang, just
his name comes to mind.
I know Joe Biden has talked about that as
well, and so have others.
I mean, I think the cultural issue around
the candidates, you've got the economic issue
where there are some on the American political
right who say, well, it just shouldn't be
done because either we can't afford it or
people haven't earned that cancelation because
they chose to go to school.
They knew what it cost, etc..
There's also the political cultural side of
the perception that college is left wing indoctrination.
And so there's some resistance to that because
there are people who politically on the right
think, well, if you encourage more people
to go to college, that's actually going to
be a problem politically.
And that's probably another hurdle that would
have to be cleared.
Speaker 4: Of course, both of those things.
I think the fiscal arguments make more sense
than the indoctrination arguments.
Obviously, yes, the universities are more
liberal for a host of reasons, but I don't
think it necessarily is being indoctrination.
I don't think it needs to be that strong now.
But I do think the fiscal arguments you can
make those like, yeah, can we afford this,
this and that?
I think there are probably some multiplier
effect.
I haven't really read all the studies on this,
but I think education is generally good because
if you go to do with the joke is underwater
basket weaving, you know, that's probably
not a good use of resources, but I think a
lot of a lot of educational things are, I
think, generally positive for society.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, I think when you look at the range
of the how stimulative different types of
government spending is, are, I don't know,
grammatically with the right word is there.
On the one hand, you've got like letting rich
people who have all of their expenses covered
just put more money in the bank account.
Right.
That that would be on the low end.
On the other side, things like food stamps
are extremely stimulative in terms of a multiplier
effect.
And we can imagine why the money is going
right back into local businesses.
And it's increasing.
It's a demand side stimulus in communities.
I think education tends to be closer to the
food stamps side than the letting rich people
sock money away in a savings account side.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I would tend to probably
agree with that.
I mean, I haven't looked at the studies on
it, but yeah, I mean, I think education is
probably closer to that than something that's
not really helpful.
Speaker 1: Nick, while while we have you here,
because you've written and tweeted a lot about
your ups and downs with cryptocurrency, and
if I recall correctly, a few months ago, you
got out, right?
Speaker 4: I got half out.
Speaker 1: You got half out.
How about what is your sense now of what we're
seeing?
I recently did an interview with the CEO of
Celsius, who obviously has a vested financial
interest in saying this is only the beginning.
This is going to be great as someone who is
half out and you sort of have a casual interest
in it would be cool if that went up what you
still have, but.
But it might not.
What's your sense of what it's looking like?
The role of cryptocurrency is going to be
in the bigger financial picture going forward?
Speaker 4: I have no idea there that question.
If I knew if we knew the prices would reflect
that, whether that's up or down, if we knew
it's not going to be that useful.
Like there's still a lot of people saying,
I don't see how a lot of the stuff is useful
or some people saying, oh, well, this is going
to take over the world.
Everyone's using Bitcoin for everything.
I think the truth is somewhere between the
two, I don't think it's the most useful thing
ever and I don't think it's absolutely useless
either.
And the reason I sold wasn't because I have
some sort of market outlook.
I was just like I bought it with a it was
supposed to be a certain percentage of my
portfolio.
It grew.
I got it.
Eight thousand.
It was up at fifty two when I sold half of
it and I paired that half off to get back
to a fair allocation of what I feel comfortable
with.
I can't have I mean it kept growing.
It just and that's what happens.
It got too big.
And I sense now that the prices have come
down.
I said, OK, well the allocations got smaller.
I'm also looking at I looked at a theory.
I'm a little bit I maybe I'll get some of
that.
So now I have a little bit of a theory, reallocation
and stuff.
My half bitcoin just because yeah.
If prices drop enough, I will buy more cryptocurrency
to kind of keep my allocation.
And it's a very small allocation, but it's
something that I believe in.
I run some data on it and we'll see, we'll
see what happens.
Obviously, no one knows the future.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, that sounds similar to my position.
I mean, I think at more than ten years in,
there's no reason for me to think this is
going away.
And even as different governments have done
have changed policy in different ways, it's
still not going away.
And the number of individuals holding at least
some seems to have gone up.
So for me, and this is not financial advice,
I've said it's like a three to four percent
type of thing in terms of in terms of asset
allocation.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's exactly kind of the
way I've kind of looked at it.
It's like find a small percentage.
I remember if I'm we're not here to give full
financial advice, of course, but the bulk
of my investments are an income producing
assets are going to be like stocks, bonds,
real estate, stuff like that.
So the bulk of my wealth is in there and that's
what I recommend for people.
What percentage?
That's kind of up to you, what you feel comfortable
with.
But yeah.
So I don't know what's happening crypto.
But if it is a revolution, if it is a revolutionary
thing, it's going to change the world.
This is kind of what you should expect with
prices.
Like it's not just going to also I'll wake
up tomorrow, OK?
We're all going to agree that this is the
price.
No, it's going to go up way past that price.
It's going to crash below.
It's going to oscillate upwards until it finds
its its final price.
And maybe it's too high relative to where.
It's equilibrium should be maybe it's too
low if it's like a digital gold, it's far
too low right now.
If it's not a digital gold, it's maybe two,
I don't know.
Right.
So that's that's the truth.
Speaker 1: We have been speaking with Nick
Majilis, who runs the blog of Dollars and
Data.
Now, here is my request to people in my audience.
If you disagree with what Nick says, tell
him where his data is wrong.
No ad hominem, please.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Don't attack my back.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Exactly.
Nix also S.O.S results wealth management.
Nick, always great to talk to you.
Speaker 4: Great to talk to you
as well, David.
Speaker 1: So one of the Republican members
on this House select committee that's investigating
the January 6th Trump riots, Adam Kinzinger,
essentially admitted to Wolf Blitzer last
night on CNN that other than one or two Republican
elected officials, none of them actually believe
that Donald Trump won the 2020 20 election.
It's not a surprising admission, but I would
make the point that it's actually worse that
despite not believing it, they continue mostly
to allow the claim to spread publicly.
And we'll get back to that.
But before we look at the video, just as a
sort of reminder, there was a proposed January
six commission that was going to be 9/11 style
is the way it was described.
It was proposed months ago.
It was going to be truly bipartisan in the
sense that we would all sort of agree that
it's bipartisan, which meant that there were
going to be five members chosen by the Democrats,
five members chosen by the Republicans.
The chairman would be a Republican, a Democrat,
rather, because Democrats control the House
vice chair would be Republican.
Every subpoena would have to be signed off
on by both the Democratic chair and the Republican
vice chair.
Republican said no.
Whole bunch of reasons why they said no, many
of them bogus.
We've talked about it before.
So eventually we get to this House select
committee, which is investigating.
And in this one, House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy said, here's five Republicans reporting
on it.
Two of them were Jim Jordan and Jim Banks,
who really should be witnesses or they're
potentially accomplices in the riots.
They have no business investigating them.
And so Nancy Pelosi, the speaker of the House,
rightly said they can't be on the commission
ultimately.
We saw Republican Adam Kinzinger and Republican
Liz Cheney placed onto this panel and on after
the first day during which we heard from four
different members of Capitol Police.
Last night, Adam Kinzinger was interviewed
by Wolf Blitzer on CNN.
Now, it's really important as we watch this
clip, Adam Kinzinger is talking about elected
officials don't believe Trump really.
One, this is not about Republican voters.
That's an important distinction, which we're
going to talk about in a second.
But let's start with the interview here and
very, very important points made.
Speaker 3: We can get the answers.
If any of your Republican colleagues, I'm
just curious, are actually privately said
to you, good work, I support you.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Is that just one or two is it a handful or
give us a give me a ballpark number, you know,
because over time, I don't know.
It's there's a lot of people, you know, and
that come up and say it and it's not any of
the ones that go on TV and spout the big lie
and then say it's the ones that are staying
more quiet that I think appreciate the stand.
But it's a lot.
And look, Wolf, the thing to keep in mind,
save one or two maybe out here, nobody.
And I think it's very important to repeat,
nobody actually believes the election was
stolen from Donald Trump, but a lot of them
are happy to go out and say it was.
Are you still comfortable being a member of
the Republican Party?
Have you given any thought at all maybe of
switching parties as you are you're going
to have to seek reelection next year?
Yeah, no, no.
Look, I'm a I'm a Republican at heart, right?
I was a Republican way before Donald Trump
since I was six years old.
I believe in the values.
Speaker 1: I'm six year old, by the way.
We could explore that six year old Republican.
But let's not right now.
Speaker 3: I didn't for and I believe that
a party was such a rich history deserves to
have people, even if it's only a couple of
us at the moment in there fighting to restore
the soul of it.
So I'm going to fight hard for that.
Speaker 1: So let's let's think about this.
I essentially believe that Adam Kinzinger
is right here.
I think there are almost no actual Republican
elected officials who think Trump won the
2020 election.
They're not good people because privately
they don't believe it.
They're actually bad people.
I would say.
I mean, you know, it's a simplistic term.
But what the point I'm trying to make is I
would respect them if they came out and said,
this is a lie.
This is the Joe Biden one.
We might not like it.
I'm not a Democrat, but Joe Biden one.
This is Republicans saying this privately,
believing that Joe Biden won, but not coming
out and saying it and allowing it to be perpetrated
and perpetuated and and blown up in signal
boosted by your colleagues.
I would argue that that's actually even worse.
And I know that there are some people who
will hear this and they'll say, I knew that
most of these Republicans had a good head
on their shoulders.
I knew it.
They couldn't really be so dumb as to believe
that Donald Trump actually won the election.
They're actually they're OK people.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's even worse that they are allowing something
like that to be continually spread, disgust,
signal boosted and reported as if it's news
when they don't actually believe it.
And the most infuriating part, and this is
where we have to distinguish between Republican
politicians and.
And voters, it is not true that Republican
voters don't believe it.
The Republican voters do believe it.
They are pulled on it regularly.
And so these Republican elected officials
who maybe they privately know that Donald
Trump didn't actually win, they are allowing
or even participating in misleading their
constituents because it keeps them politically
relevant.
It keeps them on Trump's good side, which
they think maybe they're going to need in
twenty two or in twenty four.
If they know it's a lie, then why are they
spreading it or allowing it to spread?
And it's because they know that a lot of the
voters believe it and the voters believing
it probably is beneficial to them in terms
of getting themselves reelected and the the
the voters believing it is having a real impact.
You know, when I drive by this house a few
miles away that has this huge 12 foot wide
by, you know, 10 foot tall Trump flag in the
yard that says Trump won, they really do believe
it.
And we see the polling and we see that tens
of millions of these people believe that Donald
Trump actually won so great.
There are Republicans who are immoral or amoral
enough that while privately they know Donald
Trump didn't actually win, they either say
publicly that he did or he might have or they
shut their mouths and allow the Republican
Party voters to continue spreading that idea.
They aren't good people because they privately
know the truth.
They are bad in the sense that they don't
come out and say, hey, guys, I might disagree
with Democrats on taxes, abortion, foreign
policy, whatever, but the president of the
United States is Joe Biden because Joe Biden
won the election period fair and square.
End of story.
And, you know, I'm not surprised to hear Adam
Kinzinger say it.
He's willing to say it.
Unfortunately, many of his colleagues may
not believe it, but they're still willing
to allow it to spread like a virus within
the Republican Party.
Hey, this is really, really bizarre.
This may be one of the biggest, most jarring
instances of saying that A is actually B or
that two plus two equals five, or that, you
know, that double speak reminiscent of of
George Orwell.
I told you yesterday that there was a really
important race Tuesday in Texas, his sixth
congressional district.
It was a runoff where a Trump endorsed Republican
went against another Republican, not endorsed
by Trump.
And the Trump endorsee lost not by a crazy
amount, but by about six points.
It was a there was no question that they lost.
And this was our first signal about is Donald
Trump going to be able to play kingmaker in
twenty, twenty two? Trump needs to successfully
be a kingmaker in twenty twenty two to have
a better shot at running in twenty twenty
four and to continue raising money and to
continue at the head of the Republican Party,
et cetera, et cetera.
And now Trump is calling it a win.
It's just it's absolutely bizarre.
There's a very interesting article in Axios
where Trump spoke to Jonathan Swann on the
phone.
Listen to this.
Trump's advisers are angry at David McIntosh,
president of the conservative Club for Growth,
for persuading Trump to endorse a losing candidate
in the special election for Texas's 6th District.
So, first of all, it's blaming others why
it matters.
Susan writes, Defeat Tuesday in a Republican
runoff with Navy veteran Jake Elzy dealt a
blow to Trump's aura of invincibility as a
Republican kingmaker.
It's critical to his 2002 midterm endorsements
and continued hold on the Republican Party.
Trump advisers and allies have been ambivalent
about the club's advice and thought he should
stay out of this Republican on Republican
contest.
They take the long view and are protective
of his successful record so far in Republican
Party primary endorsements.
McIntosh did not respond to repeated requests
for comments.
But this is the wacky part Trump himself disputed.
The result dented his power.
In a phone call with Axios on Wednesday, the
former president conceded McIntosh had pushed
him to support Wright but blamed Democrats
for ELSS victory.
He also said he actually one day is night.
Black is white up is down.
He said he won because, right bested Elzy
in the initial primary and the runoff came
down to two Republicans he liked.
So Trump is doing revisionist history.
He's saying, well, OK, I of these two Republicans,
I endorsed one and that Republican lost.
That might look like I lost, but no, I actually
like both the Republicans.
So really, it's a win.
Now, of course, this is absurd because if
that's the way Trump saw it, then he shouldn't
have endorsed anybody.
And this is an incredible revisionist history.
Trump then goes on to say, I think this is
the only race we've lost together, Trump said
of McIntosh and the Club for Growth before
catching himself midsentence on the word lost.
This is the only race we've this is not a
loss.
Again, I don't want to claim it is a loss.
This was a win.
The big thing is we had two very good people
running that were both Republicans.
That is the win.
Trump is notorious for shifting or refusing
to accept blame for any failure, whether as
a businessman or as a politician.
The Club for Growth spent more than one million
dollars on the runoff, making it easily the
top outside spender.
So what's interesting is you and I are going
to look at this and we are going to evaluate
it on the merits.
But even losses, Trump is calling wins and
he's completely divorced from reality.
Maggie Haberman from The New York Times sent
an interesting tweet, which was the biggest
complaint.
Republican candidates who might run in twenty
four have is that Trump gets a presumption
of strength.
He doesn't actually have any more.
We don't actually know yet for long term of
Republican Party.
But last night was an unequivocal loss in
a race he didn't need to step into.
Also, some conspiracies starting quickly.
Maggie Haberman writing.
There are also some interesting conspiracy
theories going around right now in Trump Land,
blaming various Republican senior elected
for why Wright lost, for example.
Are people intentionally trying to diminish
Trump's clout?
And the my reaction to that is, of course,
there are conspiracy theories starting to
spread.
This is a loss for Trump.
Let's see what happens on the next one in
building up this picture of how influential
he will or won't be.
He could also be influential, but in the negative
sense that he influences people to lose by
giving them an endorsement, it could end up
being like an anti endorsement.
It's just too early to tell.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail from someone
saying, hey, would covid be taken seriously
by the right if it became flesh eating?
It's actually a good question.
Speaker 5: Hey, I'm calling from central New
Jersey.
Yeah.
I had a thought about people that are fairly
covid.
And my thought was, does the thing you have
to
maybe mutate to the point where it makes body
parts fall off or is like a flesh eating virus?
My point is for people to quit being in denial.
Yeah.
And it takes something like that for everybody
to all be on board about how bad this disease
is.
Speaker 1: I do think that if covid mutated
to become flesh eating and the death rate
went up to 10 percent, which would be a global
tragedy of historic proportions, by the way,
you will see more people on the right take
it seriously, but not all.
No matter how crazy you think we've seen them
be, there will always be some holdouts.
And even if covid became a 10 percent death,
flesh eating disease, you would see the deniers
continue to deny it's an unfortunate problem
in the United States.
We'll talk on today's Bonas show about the
simmon Byles Olympic situation.
We will talk about the hundred dollar cash
offer for New Yorkers, New York City residents
getting vaccinated.
And we will talk about Florida mayors who
are defying run to Santurce with masks and
vaccine mandates.
All of those stories and more on today's Bonas
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com.
I'll see you there.